Jean-Claude Tissot merci de nous avoir
rejoint et d'avoir accepté monsieur le
ministre et monsieur le sénateur
socialiste de la loi le principe du
débat on va revenir sur deux sujets
qu'on a un peu abordés et d'abord on
commence par les pesticides monsieur
Tissot alors allez-y c'est à vous merci
de votre invitation merci féministe je
suis très heureux d'être face à face moi
aussi parce que on a échangé longtemps
longuement durant le les semaines
dernière au Sénat mais c'était compliqué
nos échanges en tout cas vous laisser
échange je crois qu'on a eu des échanges
permettez-moi de vous dire quand même
monsieur le ministre et vous avez parlé
dans la première partie de l'émission
vous avez parlé de responsabilité moi je
vais en appeler à votre responsabilité
parce que vous êtes quand même un
discours assez paradoxal quand on parle
de produits phytosanitaires fin 2022
devant la commission des affaires
économiques dont je fais partie au Sénat
vous aviez tenu un discours plutôt
ambitieux et j'étais plutôt c'est
satisfait du propos que vous pouvez
tenir et puis notamment sur les
néonicotinoïdes un sujet sur lequel je
me suis beaucoup battu et avant de
devenir bien moins 10 ans sur cette
année 2023 notamment avec il doit se
mettre à clore mais mettons la chlore et
comme vous le savez je suis un ancien
agriculteur je vais donc pas tenir un
discours caricatural mais je pense être
assez légitime pour tenir un tel propos
moi il y a eu deux plans et confitaux
les confitaux 1 les confitures 2 on a
dépensé 700 millions d'euros quels sont
les résultats vous venez d'annoncer un
plan éco 3 et donc ma question elle va
être très simple qu'y a-t-il dans ce
plan Écophyto 3 qui va pouvoir inverser
la tendance parce que quand on parle de
pesticides certes on parle on pense à
l'agriculture mais faut penser aussi à
tous tous les dégâts collatéraux des
pesticides c'est à dire essentiellement
parce que c'est un faut pas que ce soit
non plus un échange d'initié inversé la
tendance pour que l'usage et le recours
aux pesticides soient infiniment moins
important dans l'agriculture française
donc c'est votre question et on écoute
la réponse aujourd'hui on est quand même
32 % au-dessus de la moyenne européenne
pour la consommation française de
pesticides en 2% au-dessus européenne
alors c'est une mauvaise note alors
est-ce que d'abord je peux je peux deux
secondes sur phosphine et asmeto la
chlore qu'on soit au clair parce que
alors ce sont deux pesticides
l'autre est un herbicide là ça va
désherber l'autre sert sur la fausse
fine c'est un sujet très simple c'était
une molécule qui est interdite sur
l'espace européen qui est autorisé en
revanche en dérogation pour les pays qui
sont importateurs de céréales
au sud de la Méditerranée par exemple
qui demande sof à ne pas pouvoir
importer chez eux exporter chez eux de
la fausse fine tous les pays d'Europe
actif cela il m'a semblé qu'en
conscience dans le moment de crise qu'on
traverse avec une crise alimentaire
mondiale avec un problème de sécurité
alimentaire je considère que dans
l'urgence dans laquelle nous sommes et
comme c'est une demande des pays
d'accueil de ces céréales pourquoi ils
veulent de la fausse fine parce qu'ils
veulent pas que des insectes venant de
chez nous viennent sur leur territoire
c'est aussi simple que ça et donc c'est
leur préconisations qu'on applique et
donc ce qu'on trouve un jour des
alternatives j'ai aucune difficulté avec
ça
dépend des produits mais sur les il y a
des sujets qui sont plus simples c'est
plus compliqué reconnaissant le sur des
herbicides que sur d'autres produits
mais je n'en rabats pas sur la volonté
mais je n'en rabatterai jamais sur
l'idée que quand même si jamais on peut
pas nourrir ces pays-là c'est d'autres
qui le feront en particulier monsieur
Poutine et je pense qu'on partagera ce
point de vue et que donc en conscience
on a besoin de le faire et sur le smeto
la clore la seule chose que j'ai demandé
j'ai pas remis en cause
jamais l'analyse scientifique j'ai juste
dit que ça serait jamais vous ne me
verrez je vous assure
mais j'ai pas dit que vous n'étiez pas
on va pas se faire un concours de bonne
foi je crois qu'on est plutôt sincère
dans nos expressions sur le S métaux la
chlore le sujet c'était de dire est-ce
qu'on peut pas le synchroniser avec le
calendrier européen voilà il va y avoir
bientôt une décision européenne je
trouvais que c'était c'était pas
indécent de dire ça parce que ce qu'on
interdit chez nous on peut pas
l'interdire de produits venant
d'Allemagne d'Italie ou d'Espagne donc
c'est 20 ce qu'on fait si jamais on fait
des choses on n'arrive pas à monter les
sujets au niveau européen et y compris
par exemple sur un certain nombre de
réglementations européennes je suis pour
qu'on ait une réglementation européenne
et qu'elle soit éventuellement plus
ambitieuse mais qu'elle soit au niveau
européen sinon c'est la France qui perd
et vous l'avez vu en attendant
c'est quelque chose qui est né du
Grenelle de l'environnement ça fait donc
bientôt
là aussi je disais sur un autre sujet
tout à l'heure reconnaissons qu'on n'est
pas au rendez-vous de la promesse
collective que nous avions formulé mais
tout le monde doit prendre sa part dans
son exercice j'ai pas dit que vous la
prenez pas mais je suis comptable de ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui et chacun doit
dire que pourquoi on a été en situation
d'échec pour deux sujets on n'a pas mis
d'argent sur la recherche et dans le
plan France 2030 on met plus d'un
milliard d'euros sur la recherche parce
que la seule solution c'est de trouver
des alternatives mais alors pourquoi
partage carrément mais sauf que chaque
loi de finances mais là on les a la
recherche sur la recherche le budget de
l'inrae est quand même quatre fois moins
alors
que le budget de recherche de Bayer vous
irez demander vous irez vous irez
demander à l'inrae s'il pense
qu'aujourd'hui on n'a pas fait un saut
quantitatif et donc avec derrière un
saut qualitatif sur les moyens de la
recherche mais ce retard là ça fait 20
ans qu'on l'accumule je prends l'exemple
de de néonicotinoïde puisque vous étiez
sénateur et vous aviez vous aviez refusé
la dérogation supplémentaire on vote
cette loi là en 2014 si j'ai bonne
mémoire
d'interdiction des néonicotines en
France on a mis quasiment
il faut absolument encourager et vous
parliez du bio tout à l'heure il faut
encourager une agriculture alternative
et une agriculteur native permettez-moi
juste de vous dire que c'est vous avez
tenu ses propres là c'est pas
obligatoirement être amis c'est pas
obligatoirement être cependant Emmanuel
Macron c'est pas oui pardon c'est pas le
sujet
réfléchir autrement mais être sur la
sobriété c'est pas obligatoirement être
un décroissant ça veut dire on réfléchit
autrement et on réfléchit à la manière
dont on pourrait se passer des produits
phytos ça veut dire quoi vous parliez
tout à l'heure des des insectes ici des
herbicides mais on peut s'en passer des
herbicides on peut c'est une autre façon
culturale c'est-à-dire quoi des
rotations culturelles différentes du nom
labour il y a plein de solutions
techniques et on sait que c'est une
solution aujourd'hui existent et marche
sauf que et là pour le coup je vais
peut-être être un petit peu
plaisir on a pas le temps même il y a
quand même il y a quand même une force
un lobby très très fort dans
l'agriculture en amont sur la lavance
les fournisseurs les les semenciers les
les les les bailleurs de compagnie et
confrères qui qui qui qui fournissent
tous ces produits
je voudrais pas vous céder aux siret de
ces gens-là
ce modèle alternatif mais je suis
d'accord avec l'idée qu'il faut qu'on
essaie de faire évoluer le modèle je dis
simplement j'avais encore eu quelques
jours les producteurs de cerise on a
interdit des molécules du métro oui et
on a eu raison d'interdire le dimetho
non mais voyez-vous me trouvez pas sur
un autre chemin simplement aujourd'hui
on est en impasse technique voilà donc
on a 30 à 40 % des rectangles il y a pas
d'alternative sinon changer de modèle et
on n'a pas besoin de produits alternatif
non mais il faut qu'on trouve si on a
besoin de produits par exemple sur la
cerise un dispositif s'appelle l'insecte
stérile c'est un truc tout à fait c'est
du ce qu'on appelle du biocontrôle mais
si le sujet c'est de revenir à un moment
où on peut avoir ce qui a été avant la
guerre de 40 et bien avant c'est-à-dire
des crises de maladies des crises
d'insectes qui fasse qu'on fasse
disparaître les récoltes qu'est-ce qu'on
a gagné on a rien gagné donc on a besoin
de changer de faire évoluer le modèle
mais on a besoin de le faire pour
continu va pouvoir produire parce que
qu'est-ce qui se passe en France par
exemple sur les fruits et légumes on
était autosuffisant il y a 20 ans
résultat des courses on est à 50 %
d'autosuffisance qu'est-ce que je gagne
si je peux plus produire de cerise donc
j'ai besoin j'ai besoin de ça c'est pas
faux oui c'est pas faux quoi le constat
évidemment je pars je le constat mais
c'est pas parce qu'on utilise moins de
pesticides ou plus de pesticides qu'on a
qu'on produit moins de légumes c'est pas
du tout le problème
mais je n'ai pas dit que c'était que ça
mais je dis ça fait partie des facteurs
et je ne dis pas Ray homologué des
pesticides interdits je dis juste il
faut trouver des solutions alternatives
parce que si la seule perspective que je
donne un producteur de cerise c'est tous
les ans d'être indemnisé de la perte
parce que la drosophile qui a attaqué
ses cerises il arrêtera de produire des
cerises parce que les agriculteurs les
arboriculteurs et les autres ils ont pas
envie de produire pour perdre parce que
c'est du gaspillage ça c'est ce qu'on
appelle du gaspillage alimentaire n'est
pas une solution vous savez que le
principal gaspillage alimentaire il
n'est pas dans nos frigo le principal
gaspillage alimentaire c'est les
récoltes qu'on perd dans le monde et y
compris chez nous c'est parce qu'on a
pas de main d'oeuvre ou parce qu'on a
pas de produit y compris des produits
qui soient plus respectueux de
l'environnement les outils de bio
contrôle sont des éléments importants
vous avez parlé de la question des
semenciers il faudra qu'on aura un débat
à jour sur la question des semences mais
il y a des nouvelles techniques qui ne
sont pas des OGM qui sont pas les
nouvelles techniques génomiques qui
permettent d'accélérer les processus de
sélection si vous avez des variétés qui
sont plus résistantes à telle ou telle
maladie on va gagner notre temps et
quand on a ça ça permet de moins
utiliser tel produit donc c'est ça dont
on a besoin alors ce que je veux dire
par là c'est on est d'accord sur l'idée
qu'il faut faire évoluer le modèle j'ai
aucune difficulté avec ça simplement le
faire évoluer c'est pas ce que vous avez
fait donc je veux pas caricaturer votre
propos en disant on a les solutions vous
avez parlé de la technique de dire sans
labour la technique sans labour pour
beaucoup d'entre elles elle est elle est
basée sur l'utilisation minime et
l'utilisation de pesticides
elle a besoin d'un peu si vous voulez
qu'on parle dans la sécheresse il nous
reste cinq minutes c'est maintenant
monsieur Tissot alors allez-y
des choses moi j'ai une question
fondamentale à vous poser monsieur le
ministre mais vraiment fondamental
aujourd'hui si on part du principe ou le
l'eau est un bien commun de l'humanité
et je pense qu'on est tous d'accord pour
pour dire ça et et d'autres personnes
l'ont dit bien avant nous comment
peut-on se résoudre à accepter que que
quelques-uns puissent
subtiliser
ce bien commun sans se poser la question
qui elle est fondamentale comment c'est
quelques personnes rendent à l'humanité
alors quelques-uns je veux dire prendre
l'exemple de sainte Soline pas pour
polémiquer mais parce que tout le monde
connaît bien ce problème là
on fait une grande bassine on pompe dans
la nappe phréatique on remplit cette
grande bassine qui va servir qu'à
quelques-uns c'est-à-dire qu'à quelques
producteurs et et on prend un bien
commun comment ce bien commun on le rend
et je m'adresse
c'est une question
alors je réponds d'abord quand vous
prélevez de l'eau en l'agriculture c'est
vous le savez parce que vous êtes du
métier vous prélevez pas de l'eau pour
remplir votre piscine ou nettoyer votre
voiture d'accord
vous prenez de l'eau pour arroser des
tomates non mais de la du maïs qui peut
servir à l'alimentation animale vous
prenez de l'eau pour le bien commun qui
est alimentaire alors quelle est la
question qui a derrière sur lequel je
peux partager et je vais reprendre
l'exemple de Samsonite parce que c'est
un bon exemple ou un exemple de mauvaise
polémique sainte-uni c'était 21 millions
de mètres cubes prélevés tous les étés
le modèle qui a été construit avec
beaucoup plus d'agriculteurs d'ailleurs
qui sont engagés c'est des centaines
d'agriculteurs même si d'autres mais
pour des raisons
topographiques ils ont moins accès c'est
à la fin 13 millions qui seront prélevés
dont si seulement on était donc on va
passer de 20 millions de mètres cubes
prélevés l'été à 6 millions de mètres
cubes donc il y a un effort de fait ça
veut dire que le projet était pas si
bien mais si le projet est bien
puisqu'on va réduire la consommation au
départ et deuxième élément oui mais
maintenant il est signé il y a un
protocole tout le monde était d'accord
et donc il faut avancer et les
agriculteurs ils sont engagés sur quoi
sur modification de la seulement sur une
réduction du téléalisation des produits
phytosanitaires et ça pourrait être
contrôlé et sur la plantation de haie et
donc si le seul perspective que vous
donnez au monde agricole c'est
débrouillez vous sans eau ah non j'ai
jamais dit ça
c'est tragique et donc il y a des
endroits où c'est des réserves de
subtilités
qui s'imposent aucune plante ne pousse
sans eau nous sommes dans
les tomates pouvaient pousser sans eau
je pense pas dans la vraie vie
il faut de la place
donc après pour revenir
la problématique du stockage de l'eau
alors il y a des solutions des retenues
colinéaires etc mais faut quand même
juste savoir que quand on retient 100 on
a 100 qui se disparaît on a dès qu'on
extrait de l'eau du sol et qu'on le met
dans une bassine on a 30% des vaporation
et à nouveau votre question parce qu'on
arrive à la fin monsieur Tissot et à
nouveau quand on asperge on on irrigue
on repère donc ma question est très
claire comment faites-vous pour
encourager comment vous aider finalement
c'est ça financièrement
encourager des systèmes alternatifs
c'est-à-dire du goutte-à-goutte et
seulement et seulement aux productions
qui apportent une plus-value parce que
si c'est pour arroser de l'herbe qui
pour qu'on va donner à des vaches que
ces vaches vont faire du lait qu'on va
le lait à 350 euros la tonne ça ne sert
à rien de réponse en deux minutes si
c'est possible pas de souci comment
faire ou Sénat et à l'Assemblée
nationale simplement je partage l'idée
que c'est on doit gérer en commun cette
affaire là c'est à dire que c'est pas
l'affaire des uns c'est pas l'affaire de
ceux qui pour le tourisme s'en occupe de
ceux qui ont besoin pour l'industrie
donc on a besoin de réfléchir en commun
je suis d'ailleurs assez favorable à
vous c'est possible c'est pas c'est pas
le cas dans les à sainte-solines mais
d'avoir des ouvrages qui soient
multi-usages qui puissent servir
l'alimentation en octobre le meilleur
exemple c'est Serre-Ponçon bien sûr mais
serpent sont aujourd'hui les détracteurs
que vous avez là sur la table ils
refuserait circonscient la vérité c'est
ça mais oui il vous dirait que on vient
parce qu'on est sur un cours d'eau c'est
un poisson orpansion c'est un modèle qui
marche y compris en partage et donc on a
besoin simplement de dire aux
agriculteurs voilà ce qu'on les ouvrages
qu'on vous autorise mais c'est
simplement ça se fait dans le cadre
d'une transition du modèle
y compris pour dire c'est plutôt cette
culture qui est priorisée y compris sur
les efforts de réduction des produits
phytosanitaires y compris ce qu'on a
fait sur Samsung et donc faut plutôt
encourager la transition l'accès à l'eau
il doit être comment dirais-je organiser
pour faire en sorte qu'il permette la
transition et pas qu'il accélère des
processus de
pression sur l'eau qui soit trop fort
vous voyez bien qu'il y a des modèles on
voit bien qu'il y a des modèles dans
certains pays du monde y compris en
Europe où on a trop prélevé d'eau et le
système s'effondre c'est pas le modèle
qu'on a en France et donc c'est celui-là
qu'on doit privilégier et de ce point de
vue là on a une gestion collective et
commune c'est à dire le penser que c'est
pour tout le monde qu'on le fait y
compris en termes d'alimentation oui ou
non
en suivant en tout cas c'était
passionnant merci beaucoup mais ça
avance merci